hey guys i'm ryan right I'm Dan cyber
and we're gonna be watching the trailer
for a highly requested trailer called
source dan yes you don't think about
this game not a whole lot me neither
fantastic well what do we do when we
don't know anything about the game we
watched something and making assumptions
yes exactly and then people yell at us
in the comments yeah for disagreeing on
their own assumptions yeah I'll give a
high five to people that agree with me
like I did dumb and dumber 2 trailer and
people were like a lot of people were
like yeah look stupid cuz I think it
looks stupid than other people are like
[ __ ] you this movie's gonna be funny
homely or any of us really ready go
plan is like a energy what dragonfly
thing that's what it looks like
huh
is the digital neverending story
Oh
music
get away really care about the little
guy yeah anything anything small and
adorable with wings you just like is you
play as a dragonfly huh that's all looks
like a dress looks like i'm interested
because it says it looks like a castle
bit or a Metroidvania game mm-hmm and I
guess that's but if you get hands on
with the game plan sure that's kind of
what it is I really like those types of
games like Metroid's fantastic
castlevania is great well it looks like
they really invented a world that you
can explore and I'm totally stealing
words from a great right now that I
realize what I was doing that's cool
just in a whole environment of details
you can just a look upon the whole time
and stuff yeah I here's the thing it's
like I'm starting to see a trend of
these 40 like blocky digital worlds are
it seems like a very similar style I
mean no man's sky also kind of has and I
wonder if it's the lighting that I'm
looking at that's throwing me off
because I was looking at was like it
kind of looks like no man's sky but
digitally so I need to see more on
honestly before like back it looks cool
but you know I need to see I I like
maybe I just need to get my hands on it
as a trailer alone mm-hmm I mean until
the very end I was like this music is
very intense for a dragonfly looking
care yeah I don't know if it was
necessarily the best choice as far as
and joy is concerned like I can
understand like the people but cut that
together just like we need this to be
epic but you know that's just a trailer
it's not the actual weekend yeah we're
here we try to make better trailer yeah
so I don't know it looks interesting but
it's a game I need some more of yeah me
too i want to see it I want to see a
game play on it mm-hmm cuz it looks a
little slow at times yeah well I mean
that was mostly gameplay but and see
like an actual like demo um yeah yeah
yeah III know what just a thought to say
that was gameplay get dick anyway guys
um thanks for recommending that
rather to us if you're new to the
channel you know what to do subscribe
well i Ken a youtuber would ask
subscribe and like another youtuber
would ask you as a gaming channel
subscribe OOP yep we're just doing the
YouTube rules right now Boop subscribe
buttons like comment subscribe share
with your friends yeah like comment
subscribe share with your friends follow
us on Facebook Twitter Instagram vine
and yeah then you pretty much got the
whole package the whole package yeah
what do you get in return entertainment
you get this beautiful face what are you
talking about stop it dad okay no you're
you're beautiful you're you you're
you're the one is [ __ ] beautiful oh
stop it you're [ __ ] be yeah you can
go [ __ ] yourself with your beauty sorry
I got a little a house got violent a
little hurt a little okay with it yeah I
put like a girl say that to me during
sex there it is hey shoutouts let's do
it EES gooo eaz your ease graphics for
damn that's an awesome name yeah e71
percent of earth is covered in water but
[ __ ] is still thirsty what shout out
please he has like this epic name then
he makes some weird-ass comet I mean
it's true could she still be thirsty it
just still be thirsty why did he say
that do I know what what is that in
regards to I don't know whatever shout
out please well man you got a good name
your uh sex system towards women is
quite accurate also keep scientific fact
about Earth also on par yeah I'm start
saying this 71 potentially pretty cool
oh my God he's a science pimp 71 percent
of Earth it's covering water with
[ __ ] be thirsty oh how is that not
like a tagline for like a beer or yeah
alcoholic drink do you know one oh yeah
thanks man thanks I got a new line Felix
solace can you give me a shoutout we
ease you [ __ ] oh oh my sorry
about that Ryan you're [ __ ] awesome
hell yet question for you guys how come
what do you guys think insulting me
would be the next best thing to get this
they always go insult haha kidding
comment compliment is that not how you
receive all compliments insult first
then compliment yeah it's an insult
sandwich it's a reverse for men you know
like a manager supposed to compliment
say what you need improvement on and
then compliment but when you're giving a
compliment just to keep them humble you
give them an insult compliment insult ah
I feel you dawg well yeah well here's
your shoutout feel like solace boom you
deserve it because you said please pw in
a bunch of ease that's cool man that's
cool Felix like Felix the Cat solace
like the like the planes in the space
space planes spaceplanes i don't know
what i'm talking about those don't exist
yes I was trying to make a unique shout
out for you and I [ __ ] it up Felix I
loved it up whoa hey take it easy man
it's not cool man it's Felix this is a
good guy I I know just give yourself a
compliment and then you know end it with
how you suck okay so what's good about
you no no no no no okay you already said
you [ __ ] it up now say something good
um I have a thick dick great now cut
yourself down again but it's medium
sized know that did feel better haha Big
Show jr. 1 2 3 boom shadow please Ryan i
live in singapore singapore he puts
singapore huh maybe we getting it wrong
this whole time please let us know
Freeman saying the name of your country
wrong Big Show jr. one two three Wow
what's the show exactly what it giving
it its Z is your [ __ ] your [ __ ] is your
[ __ ] ah sir god ok that's where the big
show is coming from this one Junior is
no
uh-huh if it's picture of junior that's
his balls out of the ginger actually oh
actually peaks better that does this is
my penis and balls big show in junior
Inouye I think it'd be better if the
balls were called Big Show and the penis
was named you I don't know really no I
don't know well I'm trying to make
Singapore cooler I don't think the
country really needs this note the
country really needs us right I mean
they're going through an economic crisis
are they mm-hmm the outer of [ __ ] about
signal for all I know is that um when
Johnny Depp and prides of the Caribbean
yeah he helps save care nightly at the
beginning of the movie yes and then he
cuts off the court of course it of
course it okay and then you they go oh
I've never seen a corset like that
before yeah then he goes little clear
that you never been a signal uh-huh yeah
thnkx we could learn a lot from movies I
think pirates of the caribbean was the
most educational phone Weber's great
work is this